Hey guys, it's time for the most up Instagram post of the week.
[Inaudible].
All right, dude. Now this one is amazing. Okay.
Is this just a guy who is so now picture this guy he's
standing near a no he's I don't know if he's sitting or standing as a selfie,
but he's videoing himself near a kangaroo, the kangaroos in the background,
just being a kangaroo. Okay.
And it's a video and the caption is pure amazement.
So that's what this guy is right now. This is what this guy is saying.
I'm just going to play the video for you. And,
and he has got to be a hundred
percent high if he's not, it's even better. Okay.
This is what he says.
He talks about these moments in which you experience a fresh,
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct energy exploding on our nerve endings.
He's of course, referring to a Holy moment. Auto ranks, Mysterium tremendum.
If I see no Assam, as Tim duty wrote during these moments of,
in which we utter extrapolations of amazement,
we get to recontextualize the self as a marvelous conduit and a timeless
hole from which molecules and meanings flow from neurons to Nebula.
And back again, we transcend the been there's and done that. So the adult mind,
we wake into our common ecstasy. We.
Yet.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Google extrapolations.
It's stack you lay patients.
I mean, literally.
Your search extrapolations did not match any documents.
Have you ever Googled something? That's never.
Had results? What a
half hard this guy is, dude,
this guy's gotten laid. You know.
Guy has had a conversation in business.
He's standing.
I mean, what is.
Is this guy saying? And he laughs like, he's making a joke. Like he's like,
like he like, yo dude, what are we going to play again?
It talks about these moments in which you experience a fresh,
the hardly bearable of direct energy exploding on our nerve endings.
He is of course, referring to a Holy moment. Auto ranks, Mysterium tremendum.
If I see no Assam as Tim duty wrote during these moments of,
in which we utter extrapolations of a mate,
recontextualize the self as a marvelous conduit in the timeless hole,
from which molecules and meanings flow from neurons to Nebula.
And back again, we transcend the been there's and done that. So the adult mind,
we awaken to our common ecstasy. We.
It really means nothing. Does that mean anything? What does this guy think?
It means literally expecting extrapolations and transcending the been
there's and done that tend to have knots in the world.
Timothy Kozinski wrote, uh, a.
Where he talks about these moments in which you experience a fresh,
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct energy.
Experience of fresh to hardly director energy.
The Holy moment ranks Mysterium. Tremendum a Farsi nodosum.
Auto ranks experience. It sounds so much like a robot right there.
[inaudible] furious. Awesome.
Three it's a fresh,
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct energy exploding on our nerve endings he's
of course, referring to a Holy man.
Anytime someone says, of course like that he's of course referring to you're a,
such a dude
IX violations of amazement.
Have you guys ever experienced extrapolations of amazement.
Timothy Leary talks about these moments in which you experience a fresh,
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct energy exploding on our nerve endings he's
of course, referring to a Holy moment. Auto ranks Mysterium tremendum.
If I see Newsome as Tim duty wrote during these moments in
which we utter extrapolations of amazement.
In which we utter [inaudible] of amazement,
let's see what else this guy say.
That's fair. And then I'm having kind of an amazing moment.
Why don't you introduce yourself? You know, guys,
Talia's from Columbia guys and we were just having a conversation about, uh,
you find what you need to find in life when you need to find it right.
And whatever, when you're looking for something and you need to hear it,
it tends to show up.
And that was telling me that she discovered shots of awe during a time in her
life,
when she was really kind of hungry for some kind of answer or
something, right?
This guy, smile, dude, what a,
what is ha.
I am interested in psychodynamics.
I'm in how different places and spaces and people,
everything you have to take into account with your sensory apparatus informs
your subjectivity. In other words,
your experience has to take into account where you are and who you're with,
right? You become what you behold, as McKenna said,
we are the sum of the people that will spend the most amount of time with.
But if we're interested in creating spaces for contemplate of
introspection,
if we want to search the worlds within and without,
we need to be craftsmen of our fate,
we need to filter out the wrong crowd.
We need to customize our spaces and places to
unfold. This is experience design, take into account,
the psychodynamics of people and places.
[Inaudible].
I mean, I have extrapolations of amazement right now.
Okay.
Just the way he's talking and just recharge is the lump sum
of whatever who we hang out with. Right?
So what is [inaudible] about this whole
[inaudible] is basically what, okay.
So what Galileo has said was we're all walking him out around and amongst us,
we have all the external hard drive of the mind,
so to speak. It's what we do.
We plug into the extra terrestrial is somewhat of a
dark matter.
I've been laid four times.
That guy probably gets so much [inaudible] plus
dude, I could, I here's the thing about me.
I can listen to this guy all day and just be laughing and
crying and loving it. Now I know that a lot of you guys are like, all right,
this guy, come on, man. Don't, come on. Talk about other things,
but how can I do that?
There's this guy.
How can I do that?
Oh, this guy.
I liked this guy. I liked this guy.
I actually liked this guy. No irony.
It's a great quote that says, when information is cheap,
attention becomes expensive. And of course, in the age of social media,
in the age of the internet, we are drowning in information.
Every two days, we create more data than in all of human history.
Up until that point. So information is cheap.
Therefore attention has become expensive.
The currency of our age is attention. Attention is the new oil.
If you can retain eyeballs,
if you can hold on to people's focal points for even a minute and a
half, you are golden. And so the question becomes,
how do we cure rate our attention?
How do we discern mindful?
He apply this scarce resource because it is scarcity
of our own attention.
How do we not let people hijack into practice?
A kind of curatorial mind?
Is he saying it like it's Shakespeare? Why is he saying it?
Like he's in a Oh for sake, dude.
Oh. I gotta hang out with this guy, dude. Here's the thing, man.
This is why I like this guy. You have to
be passionate, man. Oh. This. Guy's blowing my mind.
Not in the way he thinks he's blowing my mind.
This guy is walking down Runyon Canyon,
which is a hiking place in Hollywood doing these, these videos.
I mean, he's saying nonsense words,
this guy in a way,
Oh man. Like you said to hold onto their focal point.
And the best part is he thinks it's funny and he's laughing,
dude. I can listen to this guy all day. God.
And he's so passionate about this. I,
Oh my God, this guy rocks. He gets a follow.